so okay
good okay great thanks for having me so
where the this slides
yeah
yeah I thought it'd be nice to put this
one man someday okay for today is there
something I can do it yeah so that
you're not seeing your murine we're just
okay yes and if you guys did it
okay so thanks for having me
this is a joint work with the song
Santosh van Paula and Bo she at Georgia
Tech so I'm going to be talking about
neural networks and in particular some
some lower bounds for their training
them
but first the the good news we've all
seen over the past several years this
wonderful success in mention machine
learning that's been brought about using
deep learning techniques you can play
world-class go you can classify images
more accurately than humans at least for
some sort of narrow tasks you can drive
autonomous vehicles really anything you
would want to do in machine learning you
know try some deep learning and maybe it
works at least in practice so the
practical success of deep learning has
been phenomenal but we'd like to
understand why and and the formal
guarantees have been a little bit
lacking a should cog oh I think there's
a unofficial motto you know I know it
works well in practice but what about in
theory so without further ado let's talk
about theory
so I'm we talking about the the
realizable case where the concept that
I'm trying to learn is itself
represented exactly by some neural
network of course this isn't really a
constraint on the sorts of things that I
can learn because neural networks can
just about represent anything but there
are some some classic lower bounds for
for learning neural networks or for
training them it's in fact np-hard even
if our neural network is tiny right
three threshold neurons and even in the
the improper setting where I'm not
trying to train a specific three neuron
neural network to to represent the
specific other three neuron neural
network but I'm allowed to use any
network architecture or
any approach to learning whatsoever
still under some some cryptographic
assumptions for example this can't be
done efficiently even for for small
neural networks now of course these
threshold neurons are not something that
you would ever use in practice and the
the distributions here well okay so the
threshold neurons can be approximated
maybe by some some some sigmoid or
something so maybe that's not a severe
criticism here but these these the
distributions that that show that these
are you know difficult classes to learn
are in some sense unnatural things that
we wouldn't think would resemble things
that we see in practice right on the
other hand even for very nice input
distributions there's very nice paper by
by Shamir recently at least some deep
learning algorithms don't work and what
do I mean by a deep learning algorithm I
mean you know take a neural network and
do some form of stochastic gradient
descent with you know whatever loss
function whatever regularization scheme
whatever you want to do as long as
you're in some sort of you know gradient
descent framework for training a neural
network so that's what we know we can't
do in general most of these these
hardness assumptions are are things that
require some assumptions about either
the activation units or the distribution
the input distribution or the specific
sort of algorithm that we're using there
are some positive results on the other
hand we just heard one of them for
example we can learn linear dynamical
systems it's a linear recurrent realm at
work or we can learn a single layer
neural networks with relu gates
rectified linear units that have some
very strong additional structure as a
recent paper and we can also do some
learning of neural networks using things
that aren't necessarily classic deep
learning algorithms for example tensor
decompositions
for again for say small enough normal
networks or under additional assumptions
about my neural networks so but what
about what about a neural network like
this we've got Gaussian input your
favorite smooth units teh sigmoid a non
linear units not too many of them and
just one layer a linear output this is a
nice family of functions in some sense
the distribution input distribution is
smooth my my activation units are smooth
can we get any formal guarantees for
this class of functions well you read
the title of my talk so no you can't but
you know try try using deep learning
use your favorite network architecture
you know whatever whatever activation
units loss function you want to use
maybe you want to do something fast
fancy with the Hessian whatever
regularization scheme you want so the
theorem I want to sketch in this talk is
that it's not going to work at least if
you're only using a blackbox function of
the input so you plugged it into tensor
flow and then compute the gradient or
you you computed some Hessian somehow
I'll need to define precisely what I
mean by a blackbox function of the input
but anything that would fall into a
standard deep learning sort of algorithm
is going to fit this picture you'll
either need an unusually large batch
size so you'll need to process that many
examples every time you you do a
gradient update or you'll need
exponential time
and I should mention you can actually
improve the batch size even further by
introducing some parameter of the the
activation units of the concept to be
learned the the true Network
I should mention that these networks can
in fact be learned efficiently or at
least a variant of them can be learned
efficiently again using using something
that's not necessarily a you know a
classic deep learning network algorithm
using tensor decomposition instead of
the gradient descent that people use all
over the place and practice using you
know a little bit of extra information
as your input about the the density of
the input distribution but we also get
lower bounds for this approach they're
just not exponential on the other hand
there are already exponential lower
bounds I mentioned this this earlier for
learning this sort of family of
functions in a more restricted class of
algorithms so more of a vanilla
stochastic gradient descent where you're
you have a specific loss function and
you're not doing anything fancy with the
hessian or anything like that though on
the other hand this holds regardless of
the batch size if I understand correctly
it's it's non realizable this the the
the functions that are hard to learn
here are not exactly this but they're
they're very similar in spirit and I
should mention also that you know the
specific parameters of this this hard
family of neural networks are also not
particularly important you can use your
favorite activation unit here you can
use whatever nice input distribution you
want you can decrease the number of
units here and still get some some
guarantees but nevertheless no matter
what approach you try to use and this in
this framework you're not going to learn
it
so let me define more precisely the
sorts of algorithms against which are
lower bound it applies so pretty much
any gradient descent algorithm is going
to have the following form you have some
function of your your current weights
for your your your learned Network and
the the labeled example so this this
this function here could be the gradient
of your loss function and you estimate
the expectation of that function over
some labeled examples drawn from the
input distribution and then you use that
to update your weights and our lower
bounds apply for for any query function
you have here any function where you
evaluate the input distribution as where
you measure the expectation of that
function over your input distribution
and where that is your only interaction
within the input distribution so these
sorts of algorithms are called
statistical query algorithms and there's
been a long line of really rich work on
these algorithms so formally statistical
query algorithm is one where your
interaction with the input distribution
so over labeled examples to your of your
your class to be learned is only through
one of these Oracle's and not you know
you're never interacting directly with
with liberal examples so you always have
some query function and usually you'll
have a tolerance parameter and what
you'll want to do is estimate you know
the expectation of your your query
function up to some tolerance so
estimate the expectation of your your
the gradient of your loss function up to
some tolerance there's a variant
this this Oracle so this is the stat
Oracle there's a variant D stat where
your tolerance varies with the
expectation of the function and there's
a different sort of Oracle that has been
studied in the literature where your
your queries instead of being real
valued and some bounded interval are
binary but your response is guaranteed
to be exactly drawn from from the
distribution and then evaluated your
function is evaluated on that that
example so there's no there's no
tolerance here it's just an honest
answer to yes library has the general
form it it was always that you had an
n-dimensional product distribution on
the input yeah n dimensional product
distribution yeah there was that one of
the lower balances that you needed and
bash size yes yeah so in practice we
substitute this is a kind of a degrees
of freedom in the distribution and it's
typically that number isn't going to be
so big so do you believe that the N is
the true lower boundary
it can't be exponential in n because
there are these polynomial polynomial
time statistical query algorithms well
do you use batch sizes that are I don't
know in practice batch sizes tend to be
some constant right some some reasonable
content and I think in in practice if I
understand correctly I'm not a
practitioner but if I understand
correctly what people have observed is
that some of the power that you get from
stochastic gradient descent comes
exactly because you're you're not
exactly estimating the gradient but
you're you're allowed to jump around
let's have invested over 28 so are you
thinking that the manifold that the
images lie on has dimension higher
twenty-eight well it's a philosophical
point at a technical but I'm just
wondering if that little God really is
that yeah okay well so there's two
there's two answers one is that you know
I think there are natural problems where
the input distribution is in fact high
dimensional I mean okay so you're saying
close to some low dimensional manifold
but the other the other answers that we
have okay you can improve this batch
size up to a parameter of your of the
threshold to be learned so if there's
this corresponds to two sort of to how
well you'll see you'll see the parameter
a little bit how sharp your your gates
are and in the true model that you're
learning right so if you think that
there are sort of sharp phenomena in
practice that appear then maybe it's not
unreasonable to expect that this
parameter s here is large in nature but
that's a reasonable question
so this statistical query framework has
been been analyzed pretty extensively it
was introduced back in 1993 by Carens
who gave lower bounds for for learning
noisy parody with this the stat Oracle
that was the first of the Oracle's today
I mentioned the V stat Oracle was
introduced later to get tighter lower
bounds and this this one bit Oracle
where you have your query functions is
binary and you you're guaranteed to get
a response actually drawn from the input
distribution exactly but not with not
with any tolerances so-called honest
Oracle was introduced by Mike yang in
2001 and there's been a lot of
successful work giving really nice lower
bounds in this in this framework and as
I mentioned this is a pretty broad
framework really I mean any variant of
of gradient descent works here tensor
decomposition algorithms can be can be
viewed as as digits query algorithms
so so if you have some some algorithm I
mean this is this is a good chance at
business framework so let me give a
formal statement of our results then so
the sharpness parameter that that I
mentioned for a sigmoid function it's
just you know it's measuring how close
you are to being a threshold function so
the the sigmoid function is in this form
and our theorem is that there is some
family of reasonably small neural
networks with a sharp sigmoid units and
a single hidden layer such that any
statistical algorithm learning these
functions over any log concave input
product distribution requires D queries
to stat or V stat with the tolerance
parameters tau where 1 over tau squared
or 1 over tau squared queries two to the
one bit Oracle and here tau is 1 over s
root N and and the dimension the D is 2
questions about the signal through music
explain how that state the statement
implies this stage okay so so you want
to you want to estimate okay so either
either your estimating your your
gradient within this tolerance how can
you guarantee that your estimating your
gradient within this tolerance well by
using enough enough examples right can
get eventually a better estimate if you
actually use the true song like will get
an unbiased fresh estimate versus the
Oracle which might eventually give you
something worse right yeah so the the
number that you need is I guess still
polynomial here and yeah go to this or
this how do you infer the statement
about that shells across the gradient
uh-huh uh yeah so I guess just
generically if I have one of these
functions here that I want to and I want
to have if I know something about its
its variant say and I want to estimate
the expectation within some some
tolerance here I need I need a certain
number of samples and the number of
samples is going to be sure you think
about that basically then the stochastic
gradient descent potentially gives you
but actually stronger than the world
so the over volume is foreign for an
adversarial world yeah I see yes I will
give you unbiased estimate and Mike
which might have additional problems
you're right you're right you're
absolutely yeah mmm-hmm that's true
that's true that's absolutely
other questions
okay so this as I mentioned this sigmoid
here isn't isn't really the critical
assumption you can replace this with
really any gate that you would want say
for example if you have a monotonically
increasing function between zero to one
as your as your activation unit then you
can do the same construction there or
even more generally basically if some
affine combination of your activation
units is is integrable has finite
integral then you can do this
this assumption so so in a nutshell then
nothing about your your your activation
units nothing about your input
distribution is making the the problem
easier you know at least up to up to
these tolerances for for statistical
query algorithms of this form and so
this is in contrast to the to the sort
of lower bounds the earlier lower bounds
for for learning neural networks where
the you know the input distributions
were very you know non smooth and the
activation functions tend to be like
thresholds so let me sketch a little bit
about this about how we prove this so so
here's the construction take your your
sigmoid gates add two of them together
and you get something that looks like
this some some bump function add a bunch
of these together and you get something
that's vaguely periodic at least on an
interval who's whose width corresponds
to the number of these these units that
you've
you've stacked next to each other and
the the the proximity to being how close
it is how far it is from being actually
periodic on this on this interval is
something that's improving with the
number of units that you stitch together
here so for any for any closeness to
being periodic here and for any width of
an interval on which you want this to be
periodic
you can add up enough of these pairs of
sigmoid gates to make this close to
periodic so this is the the basic
function that is used here's an example
of the construction with relu gates
instead of sigmoids take two of them you
get something that's monotonic and
bounded add two of them two of those
together and you get something that is
integral and stack a bunch of the next
to each other and you get something
periodic so here's four reloj units per
per period of this is close to periodic
function here so use your your
activation units to construct this
function now what are the weights of the
neural network well for any subset of
your inputs of size 1/2 just evaluate
this this almost periodic function on
the sum of those inputs so that's pretty
straightforward so I have this this
periodic function here that's an affine
combination of my sigmoid units or
relatives or whatever and each of them
is being evaluated on on the same sum of
half of the inputs so there's two to the
Omega n such such functions as I let the
subsets bury you might say hey this is
this is rank one I don't like that but
you can add a little bit of noise and
and make it have polynomial condition
number the weight matrix so this is the
the construction this is the explicit
family of neural networks that is
difficult to learn with a statistical
query so how do we how do we analyze
statistical query algorithms so the the
classic tool has been this concept of
statistical dimension here's one version
of it the statistical dimension with
average correlation gamma of a family of
function C over input distribution D is
the dimension is D if for every D
fraction of your functions the average
correlation so you average the pairwise
correlations of your functions and that
not too small subset that average
correlation is small so any not too
large subset of your of your functions
is has small correlation so this is has
been used for mostly for like boolean
functions we're talking about real
valued functions here so we need a
modification I think this is a Tele
Tubman's idea you instead of so it's a
slightly more more complex notion of
statistical dimension
let me first say what a non-smooth
modifier is it's a function with bounded
support say on some epsilon interval and
and finite integral and I write Chi Y or
this modifier shifted by Y and instead
of having average correlation of my
functions being small for any large
subset I say the the epsilon statistical
dimension is is D if any one over D
fraction of my of my functions
has not just not just small averaged
correlation but for any real number why
the Mala Mala fire shifted at why of my
function this family of functions here
composed with one of these modifiers has
small averaged correlation okay that's a
mouthful what does that mean here's the
picture makes it easier to understand so
if I have a pair of functions from this
this family of functions here and some
sum Y here for a random pair of
functions even in a somewhat small
subset a 1 over D subset of the total if
I compose these functions with some mala
fire what does that do it you know
concentrates the mass where the output
is close to to this y value even these
things are are poorly correlated so and
the theorem that is that if if this
condition holds for your family of
functions then you get exactly this sort
of guarantee for for the stat and B stat
oracles learning them with tolerance
depending on gamma your average
correlation requires number of queries
corresponding to the dimension the
number of the size of the subject
and for this this honest Oracle you only
get the the smaller
okay so so it suffice as to to analyze
this statistical dimension and questions
about the statement of this it's a
little a little technical
all right so so it's the the punch line
is that it's enough if on average my
functions have small correlation even if
I just look at the the functions in the
neighborhood of some some particular
output value okay so how do we show
something like that so take a pair of
subsets of your your input coordinates
so each so subsets of size say 1/2 each
such such subset corresponds to one of
the functions in our class suppose that
their their differences are large so
that happens generically I mean it
happens for most pairs of subsets so the
the claim to show that the statistical
dimension is large is that the
covariances of these these functions
here are are are bounded are small so in
particular the smaller than than
something decreasing with n in the
denominator so in fact this is going to
work for I'm allowed to choose the the
the modifier here for the for the lemma
it's going to work for any Lipschitz
modifier here
so let G be the the functions that I'm
trying to understand their covariance so
so Chi of Y composed with this this
periodic function so this F this these
terms here are exactly G evaluated at
two different sums of the of input
variables so this is exactly the the
form of the expression that I want to
bound and the the key point of course is
that these these two here are these two
quantities here are independent after I
condition on the the intersection the
variables that they have in common and
so all I need to do is to to bound this
this covariance here is just for each
for each one of these conditioning on
every possible value that the the
intersection might take show that the
even conditioned on that value the
expectation is still small for each of
these
so so correctly also in the paper
operation he also analyzes basically
correlation between fully periodic
functions and there he gets that the
correlation is exponentially small so
the question is like why what is the
difference sort of why you get
relatively large correlations and much
larger than than the exponentially small
with the fully periodic case mmm
I mean his had a very special form right
I mean but it's just it's a special form
but it's the same periodic functions on
the product distribution right or it
gives us like thousands of free
assumptions yeah yeah yeah it's not the
input distribution that's the sort of
what is the was I mean he is a like a
general just assumption of periodicity
and yes I remember into integral
functions functions hmm so so what's why
why do you end up with with large
correlations supposed to exponentially
small ones um so uh
I think this is the the correct bound
uh I have a question yet was it a short
senior construction on the rail line we
got you a very short and this is n
dimensional you know yes dimension no
it's also it's n dimensional composed
with one dimensional periodic function
by dreamers it was it's a 200 favorite
well so so they start to papers oh it's
100 million and then there is a free
offer
anyway it's ok we can look at yeah so
yeah in order to get even a polynomial
bound here you already need a polynomial
number of of gates so you're saying it
just because you have a limited number
of gates well certainly certainly that
would be one one-word way where you're
getting lost but still there would be a
number of gates that's not that's not
the that's not the bottleneck in the
analysis the bottleneck is is okay is
exactly analyzing this I have some
periodic function and I want to I want
to know what happens compared to at
expectation if I shift it by a little
bit over some input distribution you
know that's it this is true kind of
numerically or these correlations will
be large or you just this is the best
well it's the best estimate that I have
and I think I at least intuitively it
makes sense to me so right so the it's
fine yeah okay so so so as I was just
saying of course okay so we have this
thing that's nearly periodic okay you
pay you pay some penalty that depends on
the number of units you use to to
approximate this by something that's
truly periodic using the fact that the
this modifier that Chi here was actually
Lipschitz you can do that for any
Lipschitz function so so the real
question then is what happens now that I
have this actually periodic function I
shift it by some arbitrary amount and
what has happened to its expectation
over this sort of input distribution
here and the okay i can assume since its
periodic that my shift here is less
smaller than my period so i'm i have two
things that are that are close here but
they're they're only as close as the
period right
and now I've shifted something I've okay
so so this term here is like the
expectation of my my periodic function
under under one density this term here
is like the expectation of my peer
function under some other slightly
shifted density what is the difference
between the expectation of these two of
these two values I don't think it's
exponentially small I can give you just
a few but if you look at the infinite
range I think it's for Gaussian
distribution Constitution that could be
yeah let's talk about it offline um yeah
as I as I say I would be surprised also
because we have upper bounds right we
have algorithms statistical query
algorithms that work for these you
mention some assumptions like I said
okay yeah so let me let me mention that
okay so these aren't these aren't just
abstract lower bounds they're actually I
mean in practice you can't learn these
functions at least not with deep
learning algorithms right so so you were
asking me you know before you know is
this assumption on the on is this batch
size it's actually prohibitive well I
mean even with so so these plots here
are the best over a number of different
architectures a number of different you
know gates used in the in the in the
model architecture different batch sizes
trying to learn exactly these functions
this function family with sigmoid units
and after some point depending on s and
the the input dimension the the training
error that you get is what you would
about what you would get from just a
constant function approximating these so
it's in fact actually in practice you
can't okay
so there's still a lot that we'd like to
understand here
so you know when we got into this work
we were we were actually hoping for a
positive result here that that some-some
class of neural networks you know not
too large with nice gates and input
distribution would be in fact learn
about with with usual gradient descent
but so maybe there's some some concept
of generosity on though on the weight
matrix that does make that possible
you know maybe these these weight
matrices are just nasty ones though
there we've we've done some experiments
that suggest that you know even for
reasonable concepts here you're going to
run into problems in practice and yeah I
guess as as some of you been asking you
know yeah it'd be nice to lower the
sensitivity bounds it's a little bit
unsatisfying that they're only
polynomial so possibly I don't know with
greater depth that would be possible or
maybe a tighter analysis
any questions
[Applause]